and then there's i mean some of the
greatest rappers of all time i mean em
royce elzai jesus christ yeah
that was like it might be all right but
we gotta we gotta we gotta branch that
division together between the young and
old do you feel like m has
could be doing a better job of that
because i feel like when i talk to the
because i i'm friends with a lot of the
young guys in detroit and i feel like
they feel like such a disconnect
from him as to where like a guy like big
sean he just had that cypher at the end
of his album where he put everybody on
that [ __ ] like shawn's been
doing rivers with a lot of people do you
feel like em could maybe do a better job
of maybe like tap it in with like the
movement in detroit right now
i'm gonna work on that i think it's my
job to do that you know what i'm saying
amber's a you know very private person
you know what i'm saying rightfully so i
just think you know
detroit is so small i just
sometimes we we forget how big of a star
he is
you know what i'm saying because i
i think about like a question like this
like
like do you think every rapper from
brooklyn
no jay-z no but i do know give you a
similar example okay so let's rewind
2009 2010 2011 la hip-hop right at the
time
there was glasses malone there was nipsy
hustle
there was all these guys from la
um that were doing dope [ __ ]
but
at the time
specifically like a guy like nip like on
my show he like there was like
i wouldn't say animosity but there was
definitely some sort of feeling that
like damn
like dr drain [ __ ] with us
like the the og's in la ain't
acknowledging what we got going on now
obviously
two years later dre put his arm around
kendrick lamar and the rest is history
yeah so i just think that like i think
sometimes like you know i i think i
think a lot of it i'm gonna be honest
with you bro i've been around all these
of course superstars my whole life
i think
through all these greats dr dre's and
eminem
they all got they all got one of those
middle man dudes that tap type of man
like for dre
it was mike lynn
you know i'm saying mike lam probably
brought half of
mo or not more than half of the artists
at aftermath right so you know some
great great artists have gone through
that label yeah a lot of them went
through mike lynn
so
i think you know
definitely with marshall you know what
i'm saying i'm just i'ma tap him in a
little bit more you know what i'm saying
because i know i know it is he's willing
to listen and
[ __ ] is special right now i feel like
it's at an all-time high yeah i just
think that he he's so busy into doing
his own [ __ ] you know i get it he's an
entertainer
you gotta yo check out this he's a
conglomerate let me show you baby money
you know what i'm saying
because other than that if if me royce
of denial already show him
you know what i'm saying he's working so
hard you know it would probably won't be
away so
i think the og's and i'll take personal
personally on this to bridge this gap
you know i'm sorry
because i know all of them i know the
the pieces and the sodas and the best
chocolate pizzas i didn't mention him
earlier pieces he's crazy yeah i know
all right shout out to flint too for you
man yeah shout out to rio man shout out
to all flint